when you uh create an AGI system you'll
be one of the few people in the room
they get to interact with it first
assuming gpt4 is not that
uh what question would you ask her him
it what discussion would you have
you know one of the things that I have
realized like this is a little aside and
not that important but I have never felt
any pronoun other than it towards any of
our systems but most other people
say him or her or something like that
and I wonder why I am so different like
yeah I don't know maybe it's I watch it
develop maybe it's I think more about it
but
I'm curious where that difference comes
from I think probably you could because
you watch it develop but then again I
watch a lot of stuff develop and I
always go to him and her I
anthropomorphize
aggressively
um
and certainly most humans do I think
it's really important that we try to
explain to educate people that this is a
tool and not a creature
I think I yes but I also think there
will be a Roman society for creatures
and we should draw hard lines between
those
if something's a creature I'm happy for
people to like think of it and talk
about it as a creature but I think it is
dangerous to project creatureness onto a
tool
that's one perspective
a perspective I would take if it's done
transparently is projecting creatureness
onto a tool makes that tool more usable
if it's done well yeah so if there's if
there's like kind of UI affordances that
work I understand that I still think we
want to be like pretty careful with it
because the more creature like it is the
more it can manipulate manipulate you
emotionally or just the more you think
that it's doing something or should be
able to do something or rely on it for
something that it's not capable of
what if it is capable what
if it's capable of love
do you think there will be romantic
relationships like in the movie Her with
GPT
there are companies now that offer
like for backup lack of a better word
like romantic companionship AIS
replica is an example of such a company
yeah
I personally don't feel
any interest in that
so you're focusing on creating
intelligent but I understand why other
people do
that's interesting I'm I have for some
reason I'm very drawn to that have you
spent a lot of time interacting with
replica or anything similar replica but
also just building stuff myself like I
have robot dogs now that I uh use
um I use the the movement of the the the
robots to communicate emotion I've been
exploring how to do that
look there are going to be
very Interactive
gpt4 powered pets or whatever
robots
Companions and
a lot of people seem really excited
about that yeah there's a lot of
interesting possibilities I think you
you'll discover them I think as you go
along that's the whole point like the
things you say in this conversation you
might in a year say this was right no I
may totally want I may turn out that I
like love my gpd4 maybe a robot or
whatever maybe you want your programming
assistant to be a little Kinder and not
mock you
like you're incompetent no I think you
do want
um
the style of the way gpt4 talks to you
yes really matters you probably want
something different than what I want but
we both probably want something
different than the current gpt4
and that will be really important even
for a very tool-like thing
is there styles of conversation oh no
contents of conversations you're looking
forward to with an AGI like GPT
567 is there stuff where
like where do you go to outside of the
fun meme stuff for actual I mean what
I'm excited for is like
please explain to me how all of physics
works and solve all Romanian Mysteries
so like a theory of everything I'll be
real happy
faster than light
travel don't you want to know
so there's several things to know it's
like and and be hard uh is it possible
and how to do it
um yeah I want to know I want to know
probably the first question would be are
there other intelligent alien
civilizations out there but I don't
think AGI has the the ability to do that
to to know that it might be able to help
us figure out how to go detect
and meaning to like send some emails to
humans and say can you run these
experiments can you build the space
probe can you wait you know a very long
time or provide a much better estimate
than the Drake equation yeah uh with
with the knowledge we already have and
maybe process all the because we've been
collecting a lot of yeah you know maybe
it's in the data maybe we need to build
better detectors which that and it
really Advanced I could tell us how to
do it may not be able to answer it on
its own but it may be able to tell us
what to go build
to collect more data what if it says the
aliens are already here
I think I would just go about my life
yeah
uh because I mean a version of that is
like what are you doing differently now
that like if if gpt4 told you and you
believed it okay AGI is here
or AJ's coming real soon
what are you going to do differently the
source of joy and happiness of
fulfillment in life is from other humans
so it's mostly nothing right unless it
causes some kind of threat
um but that threat would have to be like
literally a fire like are we are we
living now with a greater degree of
digital intelligence than you would have
expected three years ago in the world
yeah and if you could go back and be
told by an oracle three years ago which
is you know blink of an eye that in
March of 2023 you will be living with
this degree of digital intelligence
would you expect your life to be more
different than it is right now
probably probably but there's also a lot
of different trajectures intermixed I
would have expected the um society's
response to a pandemic
uh to be much better
much clearer
less divided I was very confused about
there's there's a lot of stuff given the
amazing technological advancements that
are happening the weird social divisions
it's almost like the more technological
investment there is the more we're going
to be having fun with social division or
maybe the technological advancement just
revealed the division that was already
there but all of that just make the
confuses
my understanding of how far along we are
as a human civilization and what brings
us meaning and what how we discover
truth together and knowledge and wisdom
so I don't I don't know but when I look
I when I open Wikipedia
I'm happy that humans are able to create
this thing yes there is bias yes it's a
triangle it's a Triumph of human
civilization 100 uh Google search the
search search period is incredible the
way he was able to do you know 20 years
ago
then and now this this is this new thing
GPT is like is this like gonna be the
next like the conglomeration of all of
that that made uh web search and
Wikipedia so magical but now more
directly accessible you have a
conversation with a damn thing it's
incredible